president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
says the president should refuse an
interview with Special Counsel Robert
Muller unless a condition is met
Giuliani says the president's lawyer
should be allowed to review classified
information shared with top lawmakers
showing how the Russian investigation
began while the read is at the White
House Paula good morning good morning
while the president's lawyers negotiate
the terms of a possible interview
between the President and Special
Counsel the president and his allies are
pushing out messages to sow doubt about
the eventual outcome of the Russian
investigation now we're a year and a
half later and there's no proof of
collusion so stop the investigation
president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
says the Muller probe has come up empty
despite the fact that Muller has charged
19 people and three businesses with over
a hundred criminal counts Giuliani also
claims it's been tarnished by what he
and mr. Trump called Spygate alleging
without evidence that the Trump campaign
was improperly spied on everything wrong
with the government spying on a
candidate of the opposition party that's
a Watergate spy gate this follows a
common playbook for the president we now
call it spy gate yup calling it spy gate
he crafts a narrative to undermine the
Russia probe and then pushes it out on
Twitter and through allies there is no
question that there was a spy that was
collecting information over the weekend
the president tweeted at least half a
dozen times about the Russia probe
alleging politically motivated spying
the only collusion he wrote is with the
Dems Justice FBI and Russia there is no
evidence to support that spy theory
California Democrat Adam Schiff said the
president and his supporters are pushing
a false narrative to stymie the Muller
probe this isn't just a piece of
propaganda the president wants to put
out and repeat and certainly we've seen
this pattern before Republican Senator
Jeff Flake a frequent critic of the
president said Congress needs to do more
to combat mr. Trump's lies we've got to
push back harder than we have despite
the rhetoric on Sunday Giuliani
downplayed any chance the president
would actually fire special counsel
suggesting that that could draw
unfavorable comparisons to Watergate
bianna Paul